waitwait and you can see why it's always
offense versus defense it all comes down
to this hey hey let me get some love of
the offense hey hey it is time already
we're fighting no restraint
welcome everybody to ditch the playbook
football Feud presented by State Farm I
need more noise please thank you today
it is an argument that has been waged
for decades which side of the ball is
better offense or defense let's
introduce the teams on the offensive
side one of the fastest wide receivers
to ever play the game his yardage I
believe he's over 10,000 for his eighth
career cuz he's unbelievable
make some noise for DeSean Jackson next
up if you've been paying attention to
his career this season what does those
was not a surprise but boy that he
shocked people should have been a Pro
Bowler I'll stand for him now give it up
for the Raiders
Darren Wallace and as the entire nation
was captivated by Lamar Jackson he's got
a young duo that's gonna dominate for a
decade give it up for the other
speedster Holly wood
before I go to the defensive signs I
just want to spotlight the chains is
that right there defensive side we got
some talkers and I'ma put facts out
there the best all-around defensive end
in the NFL cam Jordan next to him it's
my young bro
Raiders hit so hard he's going to injure
everybody on the field give it up for
the Oakland Raider Jonathan Abram you
look clean son you look clean and to his
left
the man has bags owned in the East Coast
now for the last few years from Alabama
to the New York Giants toshing ttan give
it up for a landing Colin here is how
today is gonna work I have refs watching
you at all times if I see a phone out if
I see Google I have the power to punish
at my discretion like a New Orleans
Saints referee here are the rules I
asked a question on the app we had
thousands of responses we are gonna put
the six most popular answers on the
board
each team will have 30 seconds on the
clock to name the six most popular
responses if they don't have any on the
30 seconds we will be able to come to
you guys to steal let us play ditch the
playbook football few presented by State
Farm
because the offensive side usually gets
the benefit of the doubt we are gonna
start with the defensive side it's not
ok alright ok pass interference you guys
get all the benefits I'm looking out for
you guys all to benefit and you can see
why it's always offense versus defense
can how you feeling right now
bless ok 30 seconds on the clock
question for the defense starting with
can which coach could strap on the pads
right now and play in the NFL
go Andy Reid correct
oh the Tigers coach Bureau what
something damn up my sister my cradle
correct
come on Landon 16 seconds choppy
correct oh that was incorrect oh hi bad
is on the list hurry up oh I don't I
don't know no no - no no no one Rob yep
excuse me Robbie bf what was the last
name is Paul Revere Paul Revere wrong
Rivera not on the list there's no way he
said Ron Rivera
stop saying names they have the option
to stay too late okay too late that's on
me so here is the extra poll you got I
know I know we have two names up there
that means that four have been unset if
you get one of the four you get a
10-point steal you guys can talk to each
other
huddle up how did you feel like that
teammates that round I can be ready we
ready we ready we ready we ready Shawn
I'm gonna let y'all know you want
Holloway bro do it alright Hollywood who
do you believe which current NFL coach
could strap on and play right now in the
NFL some of a do we have Shawn McVeigh
phenomenal phenomenal the other names
that were not said and we'll see if you
would have gotten them number six Mike
Tomlin okay number four calcining Brian
Flores John Miami Dolphins there we go
you didn't know okay John I got a
football team they got a football team I
thought you weren't trying to get they
traded everybody
number three Robert salon defensive
coordinator the 49ers that's yelling and
flexing all the time alright so that was
correct answers
Hanna steel I said which coach he did
say coke that means after that round
it is currently ten to ten two fives and
a ten point steel we are now going to go
to the offensive side for their question
in the first round
DeSean we're gonna start with you we're
gonna put 30 seconds on the clock
to Sean who is the handsomest man in the
NFL you gotta answer the question Tom
Brady Tom Brady correct Oh Travis Kelce
correct you breathe Drew Brees is not on
the list
it's a weird guess Jimmy Garoppolo Jimmy
Garoppolo correct
you guys know you're handsome men George
kiddo
George Kittel not on the list five
seconds Jimmy Graham was not on there
anyway they did get three correct
I can't believe none of you didn't say
yourselves I mean Darren Waller looks
like a model slash Muay Thai fighter
install your joke from earlier it was a
good chair so you guys have the
opportunity for a steal there are three
names that up there have you convened
yet do you want to get into a group and
talk about it okay cam Jordan who is one
of the most handsome men in the NFL go
uh Nick BOSU Nick Bosa no it's not on
the list no steal Wow
big round for the offensive team Russell
Wilson number five the cleanest running
back in the NFL
se Kwang Barkley oh dear number three
this one's up for debate
oh yeah Aaron Rodgers it was a college
situation happened I wanna look how no
Cal I concede it okay so where does that
mean we stand on out three or we are is
three correct offense pulls out twenty
twenty five to ten lead alright we are
now gonna move to the second quarter the
point totals are raised ten points for
every correct answer
Johnny Howe and this one this one could
get animated oh we're gonna start with
Jonathan Abrams who is the best trash
talker in the NFL 30 seconds on the
clock go decide Jackson not on the list
and Raj not on the light whoa cam Jordan
not on the list
Jonathan a burn Jonathan Abram not on
the list
that was Devi on clowny not on the list
what Philip Rivers Philip Rivers is on
the list correct do they watch JJ Watt
is not on the list
one answer you guys can get together
before I move on to them
thousands of people entered and someone
literally wrote in the app definitely
not Jonathan Abram I just want to know
how that makes you feel he doesn't care
Darren Waller has to give me it
who is the best talker in the NFL Google
Marcus Peters I told you Marcus Peters
Samet Valley is all the less a big giant
steel let's see the reaction to the
defense blowout they missed number six
quarterback Baker Mayfield does he talk
about Baker Mayfield Unga box he talks
he talks a lot of commercials I'm gonna
be honest we've only done two quarters
and I don't know how the ham Jordan is
not on the list number four a member of
the team that cam Jordan didn't know
existed
Christian Wilkins of the Miami Dolphins
number three was Philip Rivers number
two Richard Sherman in the Super Bowl
San Francisco 49ers and number one Jenny
Lynn Ramsay all the LA Rams right he
does yeah 45:20 offensive side promise
you're not cheating
Darren we're starting with you six most
popular answers are on the board
30 seconds locked and ready to go Darren
Waller which NFL player would win in NFL
dunk contest go
[Music]
we go David and Joe who gave it a joke
who not on the list
Marquis sorry here Terry kill not on the
list
Odell Beckham Odell Beckham is correct
AJ Brown AJ Brown not on the list it's a
good guess though he's probably good AJ
Green not on the list for seconds Julio
Julio Jones correct very strong round
there by DeSean Jackson got two of the
six guys - I'll need you to step up okay
we have the defensive team convening
they so we're gonna go ah
cam has your team come to a decision on
the best dunker in an NFL dunk contest
do you feel confident yeah okay what is
your answer for the steal Mike Thomas
Mike Thomas no sir not on the list a
clean round please don't break the sex
oh sorry
number six George Kittel Titan that
doesn't make any sense
number five he played college basketball
Jimmy that Miami
Jimmy Jimmy Graham Jamie number four
may be the most dominant ABS in the NFL
DK Metcalf 3 was no joke - this man can
dunk I've seen it
Davante Adams of the Green Bay Packers
but a very strong around there by the
offense let's check in with a
scorekeeper as the lead has swollen to
65 quick I'm just letting you know this
around later that's worth 500 points
nobody is on it I know I faced 30
seconds top six answers each correct
answer is worth 20 points I'm gonna
start a Landon Collins because he's a
hard hitter
Landon hey question who has the most
whole face in the NFL go Jimmy
rabble Oh Jimmy Garoppolo no Richard
Sherman Richard Sherman no mate Naruto
very much so yes okay
fifteen seconds I don't know okay
can it be off the linemen um nope Richie
incognito no hurry up
Aaron Rodgers is correct they get to
Mason Rudolph you said pretty easily
what made you say Mason Rudolph they're
not plead to feel his bass is not just
punchable it's helmet able hey you
somebody's I am gonna get somebody in
some stuff huh the most punchable face
in the NFL DeSean Jackson who have we
come up with Baker Mayfield Baker
Mayfield he's on the list
and a big-time steal I can ask the
question Wow yes Philip Rivers is in
fact number six
wowsokappa you guys number four Eli
Manning before we give the number one
answer can I see everyone's Eli Manning
face I'm not gonna do that he from New
Orleans ain't gonna do it here and
Waller said yes please
the number one most punchable face the
NFL cam Jordan Tom Brady fans that's
just a lot of hate they want to make
million that's a lot of hate if you
notice they're all quarterbacks the
number one non quarterback that was on
the list Julian Edelman was number one
on punchable faces any fans out of
pocket all right so the offensive side
continues to go out to a monster lead no
it's a I need a 60 X
we coming back answers there Jonathan
evil [ __ ] a bike we underway by Maxis
this one is not about players this one
is not about coaches this one is about
fans offensive team and we are gonna
start off with Marquis Brown Marquis the
question on the board
thirty seconds six most popular answers
ofl team has the worst fans go Buffalo
Bills
not on the list the Eagles correct
incorrect
Kansas City Chiefs incorrect pigs bar
sealer incorrect new england patriots
correct
Green Bay Packers Reba Packers not on
the list
seven seconds Cleveland Brown Cleveland
Browns yes one Cowboys did he get it in
yeah he got it in it is correct
Darren Waller got Cowboys one two three
and six there are two other answers I
don't like that the Eagles are first I'm
an Eagles fan
the Eagles yeah why does everyone think
that they're the worst you're the one
that sent it I know what's going on you
know they get married down ten points
they booing us but we come back your
window we good no it's all good all
right so I go you love them it didn't
sound like you love them although sound
like you kind of pen that way you don't
sound like they love us some ties too
but we understand can your level of
confidence right now the steel is worth
25 pork services you do neither of you
want to say this because you're afraid
of upsetting this fanbase no okay oh you
yeah we had two discrepancies can who is
the remaining worst fan base in the NFL
watching the risk is not on the list
hey I bet the Raiders owner though I bet
your ass they are number five
and number Flair this is not about
booing this is about the fact that
they're not there the Los Angeles
charger not know how does that make you
feel Abram that you knew that the
Raiders were on them because all right
let's get a little quick scoreboard
update here as we finish the third round
hey all right Shawn has been calling a
shot the whole game can you said you got
him it is time now for the two-minute
drills we head in I'm gonna call one of
you up individually to face off with the
person on the other side the point
values will continue to go up whoever
guesses you get one guess whoever has
the guess that is higher on the list
gets all of the points Wow that is the
rules defense your team is losing so
we're gonna call up Landon Collins and
Marquis Brown first come to the center
of the stage please give them a round of
applause what's up Dan next to you you
can actually go face-to-face yeah
Marquis how you feeling right now I'm
ready
what's your prediction Landon Collins he
ain't gonna say nothing okay Landon you
got to answer first
Landon what is the dumbest rule in the
NFL take your time
they reverse Chavez rule stuff when you
do the play so you're gonna say
challenge very very challenging stuff
like basically happen to do things in it
which pass interference I'm saying yeah
final answer is pass interference rule
what is the rush
now Marquis and we'll put them up at the
end don't worry what do you believe is
the worst rule of the NFL over it's
really enough block and abet walk in the
back let's see number six what is a
catch number five the Tuck rule number
four taunting number three roughing the
passer number two overtime which means
one of you got the number one answer how
you feeling Landon is bad walk it out
the number one dumbest rule according to
the fans and the BRF pass interference
how about that
that was worth 50 points quickly wings
the defensive team within 65 pie as we
enter second round look at that VI 15
155 Sean says they're all right good -
football few good I'm going to call out
to Raiders Jonathan Abraham Darren
Waller middle of the stage football whew
hey we know who win that matchup and
practice we know now I'm Matthew Keller
I'd like you to pan down really quick
and just show where is the rest of
Darren Waller shorts the man heard he
was going to Miami and said I'm on
vacation the whole time I appreciate it
it's okay arrows out here at the pop
collar it's good the question is we're
gonna start again with the defensive
side Jonathan Abram what is the worst
NFL city it's a party in take your time
take your time
he doesn't have the clubs who doesn't
even know what bottles need go out and I
have less time to be gone oh I got a do
us go to Arby's
what is the worst NFL city to party in
Denver
Jonathan Abram is guessing Denver Denver
they are legal indemnity I don't know if
we cheated
Aaron Walter what is your guess I'm
going Cleveland he is going Cleveland
the entire audience is nodding their
head let's see let's go from six to one
number six
Jacksonville number five Detroit number
four this would have been my guest no
offense
Buffalo remember Marshawn Lynch famously
said all they got is a David Buster's
number three Cincinnati
number two Green Bay number one we
either need it to be Denver or Cleveland
and the number one answer is I gotta I
gotta ask
Jonathan why Denver Denver live looky
there ain't stuff in Denver once there's
a lot of laughs a lot in college you
enjoy Denver right I just left that yeah
yeah you never been in Denver
why you ain't helping huh what did you
think Denver was gonna be like Cole Cole
- Sean Jackson no Green Bay was pretty
good dere wall or Cleveland well done
that one was worth a hundred points so
the offensive team yeah offense jumps
back out
this is the final question and it is
worth 500 points why do we struggle it
all comes down to this can I get some
noise this entire hell value we have
heard two people talking so much that I
can't even get a word in to my right
to Sean Jackson to my left cam Jordan it
is only fitting it comes down to them
you to center of the stage right now big
time
hey disorder beyond their words what
would you like to say to your
competitors it's like my little brother
man you know he went to the same College
man he was he was my young brother man I
saw him I say to him you know he to me
right now so we gonna let him hear from
the brain yeah you went to town he was
very complimentary maybe you'd like to
actually talk trash nah man the fastest
race I ever saw with him and Javed best
going at it right so just think about
that speed there I will say I like his
shoes and it looks like we got the same
size Wow
I don't know how to result in your own
these are 16 days okay you have the lead
so I'm gonna give you the choice would
you like to go first or second you go
second just Sean would like to go second
that means we're starting out with you
and I don't know if there's a better
person to ask this question to we are
here in Miami the clubs will be popping
all week which NFL athletes active or
retired if they went into the club would
get the best table active or retired you
want to holla at your boy the holla my
boys I'm good we don't need that I
appreciate you let me go first
young young icon you know out of New
Orleans Odell Beckham jr. Odell Beckham
jr. he walking he good anyway okay it's
a really good answer
Sean Jackson turning around to his team
to game on the line I want to remind
everybody did anybody else get this
though did they get this you know that's
crazy my bed one second
okay I didn't know I didn't know we had
that you should feel good that's crazy
all right - Sean what is your answer
should be good I'm pretty sure we're
retired NFL athlete that would get the
best table - clump
i'ma go Deion Sanders Oh crying on sand
across the bow here clubbing these
probably sleep for the prime Academy by
9:30 I want you to kind of stand back by
your tables a little bit of space oh
cool okay
ain't no hard feelings Wow Wow okay cool
before we get the correct answers who
here thinks the offensive team is gonna
win let me hear some noise hey if you
understand warrants that made
who here thinks the defensive team is
going to win
[Applause]
number six he's gonna have his own party
on the beach Grunk Gronkowski yeah
number five this is why I kept saying
retired mm Dan Marino mr. Miami but he
ain't going clubbing
the fans were wrong on that one number
four marquise Browns teammate mr. Miami
Lamar Jackson
Oh hit mighty good number three I don't
know what the fans are thinking but a
maybe Ryan Fitzpatrick the current
quarterback yes i'm gonna love ya you
guys went to the club and ryan
fitzpatrick had a bottle of ace of spade
cheetos tito's and was like hey come
over would you party with rifles five i
noted the cake buddy somewhere he gonna
have to bring a cake you never seen a
keg at a table hey it might be something
new Ryan Fitzpatrick wheeling in a keg
number two
Tom Brady oh if you are always so
hostage
there's one spot left offense has
guessed it Deion Sanders defenses guest
Odell Beckham if it's not on the list
we're going to a super sudden-death
overtime is Deion Sanders or Odell
Beckham jr. number one deeper
championship now might be a sore loser
that was ditch the playbook football
view presented by State Farm
hope you guys enjoyed the video add a
left go here with bleach report
subscribe to the channel like the video
if you liked this you're gonna like
everything BR has to offer
Wow